[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend beim telefongespräch heute
von bundeskanzler scholz mit dem
ukrainischen präsidenten selensky ging
es unter anderem um neue sanktionen der
bei russland nun seinerseits sanktionen
gegen ausländische unternehmen ankündigt
unter anderem gegen gazprom germania der
russische mutter konzern gazprom ist an
dem unternehmen nicht mehr beteiligt die
bundesregierung hatte es unter die
aufsicht der bundesnetzagentur gestellt
welche folgen die russischen sanktionen
haben könnten ist heute abend noch nicht
abzusehen so wieso gibt es bei der
gasversorgung im moment einige
unklarheiten
dazu kommen wir noch später in der
sendung blicken jetzt aber erstmal auf
das unmittelbare kriegsgeschehen in der
ukraine für die zerstörte küstenstadt
mario pohl und die dort noch
eingeschlossenen scheint die lage
hoffnungslos
dort beginnt yasin herrlein sein bericht
oft sind es bestimmte bilder die von
einem 'krieg' lange in erinnerung
bleiben im eingeschlossenen stahlwerk
von mario pohl haben sich die
verwundeten kämpfer in ihrem notlazarett
von jemandem der offensichtlich im
fotografieren erfahrung hat ablichten
lassen ein signal nach außen soll das
wohl sein wie verzweifelt die lage dort
drinnen ist einerseits und dass sie noch
am leben sind zum anderen
denn die russischen angriffe auf das
werk gehen unvermindert weiter in den
sozialen netzwerken kursiert dieses
video einer jungen kämpferinnen es vor
dem krieg sängerin und schauspielerin
die ihren mitstreitern mut zu sinkt
[Musik]
wir müssen schwere verluste hinnehmen
jeder tag kann unser letzter sein wir
haben nur noch wenig proviant übrig was
zu unserem baldigen tod führen könnte
oder dass wir vom feind gefangen
genommen werden was auch unseren tod
bedeutet
militärische fortschritte meldet
unterdessen die ukrainische regierung
rund um die zweitgrößte stadt des landes
aktiv während im nordosten ukrainische
streitkräfte also offenbar gelände rück
gewinne verzeichnen können werden sie
nach russischen angaben weiter südlich
bei lohans zurückgedrängt
kämpfer der selbsternannten
volksrepublik lohans haben laut
russische quellen gemeinsam mit
russischen streitkräften eine weitere
stadt in der region unter kontrolle
bringen können
ja die kämpfe waren erbittert wir haben
es selbst erlebt aber wir haben
standgehalten
widersprüchlich sind die angaben über
die lage auf der kleinen strategisch
äußerst wichtigen schlangen insel
russland behauptet ukrainische angriffe
abgewehrt zu haben
fest steht dass der kampf um die
kontrolle der südwestlichen
schwarzmeerküste an härte zugenommen hat
bei einem raketenangriff auf ein
einkaufszentrum kam gestern hier ein
mensch ums leben fünf weitere wurden
verletzt
dieses einkaufszentrum war ein ort der
entspannung bürger und familien kamen
her und machten ihre einkäufe kinder
aßen ein eis oder spielten schauen sie
was die rakete mit diesem völlig
friedvollen zivilen objekt angerichtet
hat orte wie butscher und was dort
geschah sind weit weg die bomben und die
angst aber sind hier längst angekommen
beschuss von zivilen zielen wie
krankenhäuser oder schulen folter
vergewaltigung deportationen die
ukrainischen behörden haben bereits
tausende verfahren wegen mutmaßlicher
kriegsverbrechen und verstöße gegen das
kriegsrecht eingeleitet sie hoffen dass
sie die täter eines tages vor den
internationalen strafgerichtshof in den
haag stellen können im zentrum der
ermittlungen die ukrainische
generalstaatsanwältin irina benedict
kober sie war gestern an der seite der
deutschen außenministerin zu sehen als
annalena baerbock den ausputzer besuchte
berbalk versprach ihr deutsche hilfe bei
der strafverfolgung
und ich begrüße die
generalstaatsanwältin der ukraine irina
wenn er deckte war aus kiew gut nahm
frau venedig zu wahren
da brauche ich rechne mit guten abend
liebe und freunde sie ermitteln in
tausenden fällen dafür müssen sie ja
auch belege sammeln wie schwierig ist
das wenn gleichzeitig noch einen krieg
in vollem gange ist und und besatzungen
auch noch in vollem gange sind
sie wurden heute ist der tag des
friedens der 77 tagen für das
großflächige angriffes der russischen
föderation auf die ukraine wir haben
über viele
wie viele ermittlungsverfahren die die
kriegsverbrechen übertreffen im zuge des
aktiven krieges des aggressiven krieges
in der ukraine ist es ganz schwierig so
viele fälle zu ermitteln gleichzeitig zu
ermitteln und dazu möchte ich noch sagen
solche fälle die häufen sich morgen
werden sie sehen 100 bis 150 fälle
kommen täglich ich habe ja schon die
berichte der
staatsanwälte gesehen in verschiedenen
gebiete wir haben verstorbene zivilisten
dir haben zählen der kriegsverbrechen
wir werden bis zum morgen noch mehr
offene ermittlungsverfahren haben
selbstverständlich ist es schwer für uns
zu arbeiten
wir haben für einen bestimmten gebieten
überhaupt kein zunimmt wenn wir über die
gebiete tornetz zb sprechen
magische könnte statt mario bros da gibt
es eine
mögliche anzahl an kriegsverbrechen die
verschleppung von zivilisten und
getötete kinder wir können nicht mit
weil wir kein zugang zu dieser stadt
haben und das bedeutet jedoch nicht dass
wir nicht mehr mit der ermittelt und
druckt alles was von uns abhängig ist um
beweise zu sichern
denn
beweissicherung ist heute unsere
wichtigste aufgabe wir werden es gerade
schon es gibt berichte über
verschleppungen über über ukraine die
verschwinden sollen über zwei millionen
heißt es es gibt berichtet dazu schon
über eine million schon in entfernte
gebiete der russischen föderation
verbracht worden sein es ist die rede
von filtration scams in denen verhört
wird und schlimmeres welche erkenntnisse
haben sie dazu was sie den russen und
dann auch tatsächlich vorwerfen können
bundesweit ist sie
sprechen von den zahlen die wir
staatsanwälte nicht nennen wir sehen
verschiedene zahlen von den zwangs
verschleppten personen aus verschiedenen
offenen quelle bekommen wir diese
information jedoch sind wir sehr
vorsichtig wenn es um zahlen geht der
anwälte sie schauen auf jeden menschen
für uns ist wichtig dass wir jeden
menschen benennen können und alle
umstände wissen und beweisen können dass
der mensch zwangs verschleppt wurde
heute haben wir mehr als 20 offene
ermittlungsverfahren
zu zwangs verschleppung in die russische
föderation und die republik weißrussland
belarus wir sprechen über erwachsen und
jeden so haben die ermittlungsverfahren
auf die kinder
wenn wir über die deportation der kinder
sprechen werden und das beweisen
ist es schon ein andere qualifikation
das ist völkermord
sie ernsthaft wir sind vorsichtig nehmen
das ernst und wir zahlen nehmen wenn wir
alle beweise gesichert haben
trennung der kinder und eltern betrifft
das die menschen durch die filtration
schlager durchgehen müssen oder die
stände unter welchen menschen und
zwangsweise
evakuiert werden so ist es wenn man
mehrere tage unter
bleibt werden sie von bussen weggefahren
die menschen und die menschen wissen
nicht wohin sie gefahren werden bis zu
dem zeitpunkt als sind es telefonkunden
weggenommen wird und sie niemanden
kontaktieren können software erfahren
sie wecken und wissen nicht dass sie in
die besetzten gebiete weggefahren werden
das werden wir natürlich ernsthaft
ermitteln im moment haben wir keinen
kontakt zu den menschen die sich in der
russischen föderation auffinden wir sind
im gespräch mit internationale
organisation mit zivilorganisationen die
breite netzwerke habe und menschenrechte
schützen sprechen mit denen das nicht
sie uns unterstützen bei beweis samen
und sicher und damit sie uns helfen
menschen wieder nach hause zu bringen
und alle verfahren durch zu laufen damit
die gerechtigkeit
siegt prowin elektrowagen ich danke für
das gespräch
ich danke dem deutschen volk
und wissen sie der deutschen regierung
ebenso für die unterstützung der gestern
war bei uns mit dem bösen die
außenministerin
sucht wir hatten eine runde
gutgeschrieben der sprecherin für die
herzlichkeit der bürger die wir
verspüren dafür so
menschlich unsere flüchtlinge aufnehmen
und ebenso die menschen die weiterhin in
der ukraine
leiden wir danken ihn und spüren dass
sie bei uns sind
das interview haben wir aufgezeichnet
wäre die welt ein ort an dem sich alle
darauf einließen konflikte vor gerichten
zu klären und staaten sich an die
statuten des völkerrechts zielten gebe
es keine kriege leider bleibt das bis
heute eine utopie und angesichts der
gewaltexzesse in kriegsgebieten es ist
schon unendlich schwer überhaupt so
etwas wie die einhaltung von kriegsrecht
durchzusetzen oder wenigstens
nachträglich verbrecher zu bestrafen
aber es hat solche prozesse ja durchaus
gegeben die nürnberger prozesse gegen
die spitzen des deutschen nazis staat
oder das jugoslawien tribunal bei dem
unter anderem der serbische ex präsident
slobodan milosevic auf der anklagebank
saß gerade die kriege auf dem balkan
zeigen allerdings auch wie mühevoll und
langwieriges ist kriegsverbrechen
aufzuklären
britta hilpert berichtet darüber aus
bosnien und herzegowina
man sieht die einschusslöcher noch an
halle 3 doch die meisten kugeln trafen
menschen erzählt denen ramos seine
fahrt am 24 juli 1992 erschossen
serbische milizen wehrlose gefangenen in
der alten keramikfabrik bei prior es war
eines der ersten großen kriegsverbrechen
des bosnienkriegs
über vier stunden vorher sie mit kurzen
pausen damit das maschinengewehr
abkühlen und nachgeladen werden kann
zwischen 160 und 200 menschen wurden
getötet
der bosnienkrieg das sind über 100.000
tote völkermord zynisch maskiert als
ethnische sollte vertreibung
massenvergewaltigung
ideen selbst war hier gefangen als er
vom tod des vaters und bruders hörte
verscharrt an unbekanntem ort
dreieinhalb jahre dauerte der krieg 24
die aufarbeitung vor dem internationalen
strafgericht über 160 kriegsverbrecher
wurden verurteilt
nachdem ich die überreste meines vaters
einfanden wurde der kriegsverbrecher
kein
zufall aber auch persönlich ich glaube
nicht dass
erleben es ist fraglich ob großen je vor
gericht stehen denn russland ist
nukleare
das einzige denkmal für zivile opfer in
der region hat er selbst aufgestellt
erzählt edin verbrechen werden weiter
tut
da kommt yukos image dazu er seit neuer
besitzen der serbe weiß nichts von den
verbrechen eröffnet sich und die hand
der lagerkommandant hat gestanden in
diesem raum jemanden erschossen
da bist du dann nur noch eine masche
muss
die ermittler haben außerdem
festgestellt dass hier auch männer
sexuell missbraucht
sie treffen dann die hausmeisterin eine
serben die nichts von den verbrechen
wissen erschießung hier dienst
erzählungen glaubt sie nicht und auch
nicht dem gerichtsurteil
gerechtigkeit erfordert eben nicht nur
die macht sie durchzusetzen sondern auch
die offenheit sind anzunehmen
sie haben nummern ausgetauscht
verspricht ihn nun beim gedenken zu
unterstützen gerichtsprozesse das zeigt
sich hier sind nur ein schritt zur
versöhnung es braucht auch das
menschliche die begegnung
das geschädigte ukraine jetzt weckt bei
vielen menschen die die balkankriege
erlebt haben furchtbare erinnerungen und
neue ängste
zumal die politische lage auf dem
westbalkan alles andere als stabil ist
mehr hintergründe dazu finden sie online
auf zdf heute
und mit den nachrichten bieten wir jetzt
erst mal nach deutschland heinz und zwar
nach schleswig holstein nach der
landtagswahl dort hat ministerpräsident
günther seiner cdu vorgeschlagen mit
grünen und fdp über eine neuauflage des
dreierbündnisses zu sprechen auf einem
kleinen landesparteitag der cdu sagte
günther er wolle in den anstehenden
gesprächen auch über diese möglichkeit
reden für kommenden dienstag sind sowohl
mit den grünen als auch mit der fdp
sondierungsgespräche geplant nach dem
wahlergebnis würde es für die cdu auch
für ein zweierbündnis reichen
der bundesrat hat in einer sondersitzung
über die regierungspläne zum ergänzungs
haushalt beraten der sieht vor allem
geld für entlastungen vor wie eine
energiepreis pauschale und einen
kinderbonus auch der bundesrat sprach
sich für maßnahmen zur entlastung aus
kritisierte aber die regierungspläne so
wurde auf milliarden- belastungen für
länder und kommunen verwiesen und mehr
finanzielles engagement des bundes
gefordert
im kampf gegen sexualisierte gewalt an
kindern könnte das internet künftig
deutlich stärker durchleuchtet werden
nach einem gesetzentwurf der
eu-kommission könnten online-dienste
verpflichtet werden mit hilfe von
software nach entsprechenden
darstellungen zu suchen und zu melden
ein eu zentrum soll die technologien
dazu bereit stellen alleine 2021 seien
weltweit 85 millionen bilder und videos
gemeldet worden die sexualisierte gewalt
an kindern zeigen
nach dem tod einer korrespondentin des
tv senders al jazira haben zahlreiche
länder eine unabhängige untersuchung
gefordert während einer razzia in
dschenin war es zu einem heftigen
feuergefecht zwischen israelischen
sicherheitskräften und militanten
palästinensern gekommen
die journalistin china boa klever dabei
tödlich am kopf getroffen worden seit
märz kommt es in israel immer wieder zu
terroranschlägen israels armee verstärkt
zeit ja ihre einsätze im besetzten
westjordanland
nach den ausschreitungen zwischen
regierungsgegnern und befürwortern in
sri lanka hat das
verteidigungsministerium nun zusätzliche
militär truppen in der hauptstadt
stationiert außerdem erteilte es dem
militär einen schießbefehl gegen
gewalttätige demonstranten und plünderer
die proteste dauern seit wochen an
auslöser ist die schwere
wirtschaftskrise minister präsident
rajapaksa war bereits am montag infolge
der unruhen zurückgetreten
die bundeswehr soll sich weiterhin an
der un-stabilisierungsmission im
westafrikanischen mali beteiligen die
bundesregierung stimmte heute für eine
verlängerung des einsatzes um ein jahr
das kontingent soll dabei von 1100 auf
bis zu 1400 soldaten aufgestockt werden
die eu ausbildungsmission in mali
hingegen soll sich laut antrag künftig
auf das nachbarland niger begrenzen der
bundestag muss den anträgen noch
zustimmen
wenn ein politiker oder eine politikerin
immer wieder eine etwas unglückliche
figur abgibt spricht man ja gern davon
dass es ihm oder ihr an forthin fehlt
vieles von dem was
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht vorgehalten bild vorgehalten
wird fällt wohl in diese kategorie des
glücklos agierenden falsche kleidung
beim truppenbesuch das unselige 5000
schutzhelme statement darüber dass man
sich auch in der ukraine mokierte oder
zuletzt der sohle mann der sich auf
instagram regierungshubschrauber
präsentierte nichts davon sind aber
stolpersteine über die eine ministerin
stürzt schwerer wiegt kritik dass es
lambrecht und dem von ihr ins
ministerium mitgebrachten team an
fachlicher kompetenz fehlt um ein
verteidigungsministerium in solch
dramatischen zeiten zu führen christiane
hübsche berichtet eine geschichte mit
geschmäckle heißt es mangelnder
politischer instinkt
verteidigungsministerin lambrecht hat
ein foto problem der 21-jährige im
hubschrauber der luftwaffe ist ihr sohn
stolz postet er es bei instagram kurz
vor ostern fliegen sie gemeinsam zu
einem truppenstützpunkt in
norddeutschland unweit ihres ferienortes
auf sylt wie praktisch die
verteidigungsministerin im
verteidigungs- modus ich bin als
ministerin in der situation dass ich
sehr wenig zeit habe für privatleben und
insbesondere für den kontakt mit meinem
sohn und deswegen kann man diese
entscheidung in frage stellen dafür habe
ich auch verständnis ich bin um
verständnis dafür dass es darum geht
eben auch den kontakt zum kind weiter
aufrecht zu halten lambrecht habe die
mitnahme vorher angemeldet und
inzwischen 261 euro für den flug ihres
sohnes bezahlt sagt das ministerium
es ist legal sagt die ministerin aber
ist es auch politisch klug nein sagen
sie im verteidigungsausschuss ich kann
nur so viel sagen es ist juristisch
offensichtlich möglich sind keine
juristin nicht alles was juristisch
möglich ist ist um den politisch
sinnstiftend die ministerin muss jetzt
mal beweisen dass sie dieses amt so
ernst nimmt dass die bundeswehr ihr auch
vertrauen kann hier ist nachhol arbeit
zu leisten die zeitung die welt
berichtet es gab vorab den inoffiziellen
hinweis die volljuristin lambrecht
behalte sich rechtliche schritte gegen
eine mögliche berichterstattung vor
politische kommunikation am limit ich
behalte mir bei allen äußerungen die
über mich oder meine familie getroffen
werden vor entsprechend dann auch darauf
zu reagieren wenn es zu falschen
tatsachenbehauptungen konnten sie hat
dieses amt nicht gewollt heißt es sie
irritiert wenn sie in hier ist zum
truppenbesuch in die wüste kommt ein
andermal schreibt sie sie habe sich mit
der bundesmarine getroffen dabei heißt
die schon lange deutsche marine der ruf
der ministerin nach fünf monaten mehr
als angekratzt ihrer amtsführung
zweifelhaft lamprecht als
verteidigungsministerin ungeeignet auf
dem falschen posten sie habe jedes
politische gespür verloren es ist
insgesamt nicht ideal und das finden
natürlich auch viele soldaten soldaten
in der bundeswehr so wenn immer wieder
ihre oberste führung sich von null an
einarbeiten muss in dieser doch sehr
komplexe materie der
verteidigungspolitik das fällt natürlich
leichter wenn da ein bisschen mehr
kontinuität drin wäre in der expertise
an der spitze für die 5000 m die sie der
ukraine verspricht wird lambrecht vom
ausland verlacht später sagt sie die
bundeswehr habe keine schweren waffen
übrig dann verspricht sie sie doch und
einen ringtausch mit panzern doch all
das steht
klar ist dass für viele der sachen die
zugesagt worden sind dass sie jetzt
geliefert werden sollen also zum
beispiel
gibt aber auch die haubitzen
offensichtlich zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
dass er keine exportgenehmigungen gibt
olaf scholz lässt heute zum zweiten mal
ausrichten er arbeite mit der ministerin
eng und vertrauensvoll zusammen immer
dann weiß man es läuft gar nicht gut
und bei uns geht es jetzt mit den
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen des
ukraine träges weiter wer die ukraine
hat heute die durchleitung von
russischem gas gedrosselt und zwar durch
das gebiet lugansk im osten des landes
weil der betrieb ort wegen des krieges
nicht mehr kontrolliert werden könne bei
der iana wie sind die reaktionen
spezielle deutschland darauf also man
reagiert ziemlich gelassen das
wirtschaftsministerium beruft sich auf
die bundesnetzagentur die die
gasspeicher ja ganz genau im blick hat
und sie sagt die versorgungssicherheit
sei weiterhin gewährleistet was an gas
derzeit fehlt kompensieren norwegen und
die niederlande
die betroffene pipeline in der ukraine
ist auch nur eine und nicht die haupt
pipeline noch denkfabrik bruegel gehen
weniger als 10 prozent des russischen
gases für die eu durch die pipeline in
lugansk die große masse kommt über die
pipeline nord stream 1 direkt aus
russland
der fall zeigt wie unkalkulierbar die
gasversorgung derzeit ist außerdem
trifft jede verknappung zur zeit auf
sehr nervöse märkte bislang sind die
gaspreise hoch aber stabil geblieben und
preisaufschläge
einzudämmen und die versorgung zu
sichern haben sich die eu-länder gerade
auf verpflichtende gasreserven geeinigt
jedes land soll zum winter die speicher
fast komplett gefüllt haben ein
entsprechendes gesetz und in den
nächsten monaten in kraft treten ein
blick noch auf den dax der auch heute
kräftig zulegen konnte über 2 prozent im
plus in der eurozone wird der zeitpunkt
der zinswende immer konkreter ezb chefin
lagarde hat heute eine baldige
zinserhöhung in aussicht gestellt im
juli könnte es soweit sein munkelt man
weil er gehört vielen dank
und jetzt die zahlen vom lotto am
mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
2 24 25 27
28 45 und die superzahl 4 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
wir menschen sind bekanntlich geschöpfe
die gerne gestalten wir bauen uns nicht
einfach nur eine höhle oder ein
fernsehstudio wir designen und da gehen
wir jetzt mal kurz in vergangene zeiten
zurück in den look der seventies
ungefähr so hat unser heute journal
studio ende der 70er ausgesehen das
gesamte erscheinungsbild des zdf wurde
damals von otl aicher entwickelt der an
diesem freitag 100 jahre alt geworden
wäre ein design visionär der in seinem
metier auch für eine zeitenwende steht
als er nämlich den auftritt für die
olympischen spiele in münchen
1972 entwirft war das radikal neu keine
traditionellen bayrischen schnörkel
stattdessen bereitet eicher der modernen
bundesrepublik gestalterisch den weg
claudio armbruster blickt für uns 50
jahre zurück
offen und freundlich ein neues
deutschland das sollten die olympischen
spiele 1972 zeigen und er sollte diese
aussage sichtbar machen in farbe form
und gestaltung otl aicher
wenn wir bestimmte farben nehmen
leichte farben unpathetische färben dann
geht es uns nicht darum nur einen
ästhetischen rahmen zu schaffen sollen
wir eine bestimmte wenn ich ja auch wohl
sogar politische aussage zahlen
nicht kunst sondern gestaltung und
wiedererkennung
konsequentes corporate design und leiche
hat sich um alles gekümmert bei den
spielen 72 von den fahnen über die
hinweisschilder von den parkscheinen bis
zu den essensmarken und er hat alles
angeordnet rund um die grundfarben blau
orange grün also farben des regenbogens
auch die farben der oberbayerischen
landschaft und er wollte damit ein
kontrapunkt setzen zur rot und schwarz
und gold den farben der diktaturen des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
otl aicher geboren 1922 und von
vornherein gegner des ns-regimes
er war befreundet mit der familie scholl
und stand ihr bei nach der hinrichtung
von hans und sophie
später heiratete er deren schwester inge
scholl mit ihrer gründete er 1953 die
hochschule für gestaltung in polen und
wurde zum designer des modernen
demokratischen deutschland der kranich
der schriftzug das blau und gelb wegen
eicher ist klar das ist lufthansa das
sparkassen zeichen das zdf in den 70ern
und 80ern alles
will hat im pfosten cool war mit ihm
befreundet und kennt sein gesamtwerk
sehr gut die frage woran erkennt man das
ist ein eicher an der
reinheit dass strukturen der bildgebung
das ist unübertroffen er ist ein
struktur denker und sehr gewesen das
sehen sie eine piktogrammen die ja
weltweit bekannt geworden sind er ist
nicht der erfinden der ikonischen
vermittlung von informationen das haben
andere vor ihm schon gemacht aber die
reinheit die sauberkeit die schärfe die
struktur das ist seine handschrift
seine piktogramme dank reicher weiß man
auch ohne worte und welchen sport es
geht wo die duschen und treffpunkte sind
visuelle kommunikation
aus den fröhlichen spielen 72 wurden
dramatische
doch es bleiben nicht nur die attentate
in erinnerung sondern auch sportliche
leistungen und
das werkl eichers
ganz großer das war es von uns gleich im
auslandsjournal erwartet sie unter
anderem eine reportage über finnlands
weg die natur und um 0.30 meldet sich
wohl schmiese mit unserem heutigen
update ausführlich zum mali einsatz der
bundeswehr wiedersehen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon genannte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter ein rückblick in den april
und da hatten wir es über europa
teilweise zu niedrige werte in teilen
europas also zu kalt das lag daran dass
die eisige luft aus der arktis mehr
regional direkt zu uns kam und
dementsprechend viel da april eher
durchschnittlich aus in europa aber
global betrachtet richtung indien zum
beispiel war es der zweitwärmste april
seit 1901 in pakistan sogar der wärmste
seit
1961 und laut welt meteorologie
organisation nehmen die temperaturen in
den nächsten jahren immer weiter zu und
könnten die 15 grad marke bis 2026
kurzfristig überschreiten die
wahrscheinlichkeit dafür lag 2015 30
prozent und bis 2026 bei 50 prozent
schauen wir auf das wetter und da haben
wir es mit schauern und gewittern im
norden zu tun die verlagern sich nach
osten hin im süden klart es auf und die
temperaturen gehen zurück auf 9 grad
richtung nordsee und 16 grad im
südwesten 17 im osten und tagesverlauf
morgen gibt es einige schauer und
gewitter im süden können durchaus
kräftiger ausfallen vor allem nach osten
hin ist es aber ziemlich sonnig bei
höchsten temperaturen von 15 bis 16 grad
im nordwesten und bis zu 27 grad im
süden deutschlands hier deutlich wärmer
als im norden die nächsten tage am
freitag im süden gewitter und im norden
schauer bei 14 bis 25 grad und sonntag
wieder deutlich wärmer bis 29 grad ein
schön habt